what's going on guys this is rob and we
are back with batman the imposter which
is just a ridiculously good story god i
absolutely love this uh so what we end
up doing here is really picking up in
the aftermath of the meeting that bruce
wayne initially had with leslie tompkins
where she was diagnosing him and that
kind of a thing and it was kind of like
if you don't come to these regular
meetings at dawn uh then basically i
will report you to the cops and we
actually switch over to a person by the
name of detective blair wong now here's
the thing over here in a place called
the wesker building there's essentially
an incident that had basically taken
place here uh involving the batman being
involved and so on and so forth and this
is kind of interesting thing so a lot of
you guys who are familiar with the name
wesker from batman comics you guys know
him as the ventriloquist now there's
nothing to indicate that's actually him
it is entirely possible that's the
benefit of when you're talking about
having these alternate reality stories
is that people just kind of turn out
differently than they normally do uh and
so it's entirely possible here that
wesker wesker's not necessarily the guy
that we're familiar with but just some
different variation the thing about this
though and what's really really
interesting is there's a lot of veiled
threats here and a lot of just sort of
lording things over uh detective wall
and the reason for this is because when
footage is handed over to her involving
the batman having been here and then
actually having operated for three days
as basically a construction worker
hiding among everybody in plain sight
because they all assumed he was just
some kind of new hire that once she
actually meets with wesker initially he
kind of gives her the rundown sort of
explains what's going on and as far as
like what he wants to have done and
ultimately he says like i want to know
like what you know this i want to be
updated on this investigation right i
want to know what you know and the thing
about this is one she doesn't know a
whole lot but then two where she
basically says no right like i mean i
can't discuss an open investigation with
a private citizen he kind of lords this
thing over her head and saying like when
the previous mayor that we had had
basically misappropriated a whole ton of
funds it was wesker capital that
basically that financially bailed out
the city of gotham so that the city
could continue providing water and
electricity and resources to its 12
million citizens and so it's one of
those things where it's like you owe us
basically and at the end of the day
detective wong still stands her ground
and is like that's not gonna happen
right like you know we appreciate
everything you've done and how you've
been a benefactor for the gotham city
police department yada yada but at the
end of the day uh that's not happening
i'm not gonna violate the law in order
to appease you because you feel like the
city of gotham owes you a thing and so
that's ultimately when wesker kind of
drops this big bomb on her which is
really more like a veiled threat when he
essentially says look here's the thing
right the the biggest issue that you
need to contend with as far as the
batman goes is he makes you and your
fellow police officers look like idiots
right he's cleaning up the streets in a
way that you simply just can't do here's
the problem he's bad for business he's
bad for the one percent buildings are
getting destroyed different things like
that where he blew up a wayne industries
building right he's cost people money
and so while the citizens in the street
may very well cheer his name and while
he does make your life easier the
question you really need to be asking
yourself is what happens when the
wealthy and the powerful get tired of
what's going on and take things into
their own hands and that's what's really
intriguing here now it's kind of an
aside because this is something that
we'll sort of circle back around to
later there is a point when she leaves
wesker's office and is going down the
elevator that she basically meets
wesker's son who looks like he's
struggling with some kind of mental
illness kind of babbling to himself a
little bit then ultimately just leaves
literally having a whole conversation
with himself and then just leaves right
uh so that's not the most important
thing here at the moment but what she
says is that wesker does have a good
point the ability for gotham city to
continue on financially quite literally
hinges on the one percent on the most
powerful people and in a lot of ways
that's true right for like most cities
out there they're able to function
partly through the tax dollars that they
charge the average person but there's
only so much money people can pay in
taxes a lot of that money is funneled
through with regards to the wealthiest
people so what happens when the
wealthiest people in your city pull out
not only do the tax benefits from that
go away but also the jobs go away right
with the employer's leave and so in a
lot of ways it's very very easy for the
wealthiest individuals in society to
essentially hold a city hostage now it's
not necessarily wrong right as a source
of employment you do have at any point
in time to pull your employment out to a
different location right at the end of
the day the difference between employers
and you as a general person hiring a
contractor is that you want the greatest
reward for the least amount of money
possible right you want to save money
everywhere you can so we're all kind of
in that same boat right maximizing the
amount of money we have minimizing the
amount of money we spend right so that's
one of the reasons why in that in that
way it makes sense but what's really
going on here as far as westeros is
concerned it is really kind of you know
again sort of threatening the city of
gotham right like we can just pull out
like we can just leave or as the
wealthiest individuals we can just take
the law into our own hands and do
something on our own and so once
detective wong gets back to the precinct
she's immediately called into the
meeting room by her superior and once
she gets in there it's not one of those
things where she's being screamed at
because she was like interrogating the
wrong guy right because you know she's
asking questions of like the really
powerful or denying them requests or
anything like that and it's making her
lie you know making her superior's life
rough there's actually a huge basically
a batman task force going on here and
essentially what's happened is batman's
killed a guy now we're not talking about
the last person who's throaty slash when
they were on the street instead this is
actually a lot more brutal what what
basically has gone on here is that there
is camera footage that was actually
handed over by wesker capital but
there's camera footage here where
essentially there's three guys who are
bound and gagged and masked that are on
their knees on top of a roof and batman
just kind of keeps them there for about
two minutes and then starts kicking them
off individually like literally kicking
them to their deaths now that's kind of
the crazy thing is because they do get
like a really really blurry image as far
as he as far as he goes but it is enough
to basically look like batman right it
looks exactly like something that
batman's doing now on the surface and
and coming from like a main dc universe
comic it's like i mean okay look like
you know this this like we know it's
obviously not batman it's only a matter
of time before people figure it out
there's this really really cool scenario
that scenario that comes into play here
when you basically move away from from
detective wong right the kind of
conversation that they're having this
idea that they're kind of like okay so
like at this point it was one thing when
we could turn a blind eye to this idea
of batman beating up criminals in the
middle of the night because i mean sure
like he's he's pummeling him and
honestly if he didn't do it we as the
cops probably would right so if anything
he saved us some broken knuckles or we
could just kind of beat him up a little
bit more and get a little more
information out of him the other thing
that kind of goes on here is wong sort
of reminisces about the early days right
the batman's only been around for about
three years and that when he first
popped up on the scene there were a lot
of people who were calling in about the
the idea of you know some vampire bat
flying around the city different things
like that about how criminals were just
being dropped off on the doorstep of
gotham city's police department and they
were swearing up and down you know by
rumors and things like that that this
batman guy was basically invincible they
would shoot him and then he would get
back up right or he would jump into the
sky disappear and then reappear behind
him or something along those lines and
then there were small little things that
seemingly didn't seem to make a whole
lot of sense right like you know a
network of zip lines that were set up
around the city that nobody ever really
seemed to notice most likely because
they blended into power lines or because
for whatever reason people just didn't
really look up you'd be amazed what
percentage of humans actually don't look
up on a regular basis is actually a
pretty astounding number uh but then it
was also things like motorcycles in the
sewer systems and so on and so forth so
whatever was going on here and really
wong put it together pretty fast whoever
this batman guy is he was basically able
to rig up the city whether it was
through motorcycles or or zip lines or
whatever to get around pretty quickly
which of course she figures out really
just requires a lot of money but at that
point we switch over to leslie
thompson's right and this is the whole
thing about you know the idea of the
imposter and so on and so forth we
switched over to leslie tompkins who
initially gets ready to call the cops
because by the time dawn arrives batman
simply just hasn't shown up yet of
course he basically makes it in there at
the very last minute and she holds up a
newspaper that basically says like
batman kills right the newspaper
reporting on the video footage of these
guys being kicked off the the roof of a
building and when she asks him like is
it true of course his response is i
thought you knew my profile now here's
the kicker right she asked him to take
off his mask tell me that doesn't look
like robert pattinson it looks exactly
like robert pattins's batman he'll never
convince me otherwise which is why i say
i think this imposter story is basically
designed to either take place in the new
batman movie you know landscape or
they're just building on the popularity
of it i don't know i haven't seen the
batman yet i'm actually going to see it
tomorrow on march 3rd at 7 pm at the
time that we're recording this video but
regardless you know she kind of asks
like you know okay if this wasn't you
then how could this possibly be the case
and he simply says there's an imposter
right like there's somebody out there
pretending to be batman and it's a
brilliant setup right hide behind my
mask leave me the blame for killing
spree now here's the kicker to this
here's the caveat right by and large
batman is not overly trusted now and
they even say things like the former uh
the former commissioner jim gordon and
things like that indicating that he's
not part of the picture anymore uh but
the thing about this is that as far as
the world is concerned they don't know
that batman is bruce wayne and so
because of this a person masquerading as
batman and just openly and brazenly
killing people requires one of two
things right it kind of forces the hand
of batman either he can turn himself in
and then basically say like that wasn't
me he can capture that person on his own
but regardless public perception has now
shifted to the idea that batman is
basically a killer right brazenly and
openly killing people and not only doing
it in that capacity but doing it
ruthlessly right like just mercilessly
that kind of a thing now of course under
normal circumstances you might say that
the court of public opinion doesn't
matter uh but it actually does right
like prison sentences things like that
like a lot of the punishments that
people receive or even just the
launching of investigations are often
times done based on public opinion which
really begs the question why are people
who can't even manage their own lives
having any involvement in the lives of
other people right you know fix yourself
first worry about others later but the
thing about this is where leslie asks
like you know are like have you do you
have any leads and he's kind of like i
mean i've asked around a little bit and
of course as you guys know when batman
asks around it usually involves people
just being just having the absolute
target out of him
right you know he's kind of like i've
asked these different these different
groups here and there and you know of
course i beat them up along the way you
know beat a few of them but none of them
are really the imposter like none of
them have anybody in their group that is
the imposter now one of the things he
also does is he talks about penguin
right talks about cobblepot he says like
i mean he was he was convinced that i
was finally going to kill him uh so as
soon as i showed up he basically pissed
his pants but uh but it's not him right
like he's not the guy who's the imposter
and seemingly has no information on
anybody who is the imposter and the
funny thing is that as he's recounting
this to leslie there's almost a kind of
pride in the idea that oswald cobblepot
was just so terrified of batman and the
response of bruce is fear is the most
vicious weapon right fear is the thing
that keeps people in line right fear of
the consequence but the thing about that
is leslie kind encounters it says like
the police have tolerated you because in
some ways you've made their jobs easier
but if they believe you're crossing this
line that justification all goes out the
window it's one thing to just beat the
hell out of criminals it's another to
openly kill people right they simply
just can't tolerate that right they have
to at least in some capacity maintain
the law besides if anybody in the city
of gotham is going to be killing
innocent people it's gonna be the cops
right you guys know that's their
territory
[Laughter]
but nonetheless right it's one of those
those things because initially when
they're kind of kind of talking here
right she's like you can't be feared as
a murderer and enjoy the same leniency
from the gossip city police department
right you can't have people out there
being afraid of the fact that you're
going to kill them and the gotham city
police department turned a blind eye
right you have to believe that that's
the case and where he doesn't initially
say anything she kind of asks like you
aren't actually thinking of letting this
imposter just sort of continue out there
and kill people and the reason why she's
asking that question is because if bruce
wayne did that it would kind of give him
the best of both worlds right it would
allow him to operate as the batman which
would kind of drum up fear even more
because essentially he'd be in two
places at once right so there's like
double the batman running around right
which would make criminal elements
almost even more impossible he gets to
keep his conscience clean by not
actually killing anybody but letting
someone else do it instead that's one of
those things where it's kind of like
it's entirely possible now of course
he's like no i'm gonna stop this guy
right like i'm gonna you know defeat
this guy and bring it in you know bring
it into it all and that's when leslie
says then you need to do it fast because
you're running out of time and so what
you end up doing here is kind of
switching over to the small little aside
with this guy named otis right who's
basically a guy that kills rats and he
shows up at this guy's place where this
is your apartment building seemingly and
this guy's like look man uh i'm tired of
calling you here right like i mean like
i don't want you like running the rats
away i don't want you shooing them off
like i want you killing them and the
guy's like well i mean i try to be
humane you know he's like do you have
poison and otis is like yeah man he's
like then use the poison on these rats
or else i want to make you eat it so
obviously this guy's you know treating
otis like crap now a lot of that's
because otis allows them to right
because otis is just this guy who's just
really really miserable and down on his
luck uh for those of you guys who are
familiar with this basically bear with
me here so here's the thing uh
so the the whole thing about this is
that of course this guy is very much
kind of with these rats and this idea
that in in a lot of ways he he kind of
observes people that he's almost really
more of a fan of rats than he is of
human beings he's like you know they're
scared because they're small they move
quick they've got long faces teeth a
tail right they're synonymous with
diseases he totally understands that he
says but dogs can be small dogs can move
quick they have long faces they've got
teeth a tail dogs carry diseases dogs
are more likely to hurt you than a rat
ever will a dog can kill you but we love
dogs right and that's one of the things
again where he talks about the the weird
and sort of hypocritical nature of
humanity right there's no rhyme or
reason as to why it is people
differentiate between dogs and rats
other than the fact that dogs are just
socially acceptable and that's really
the only thing right somewhere along the
line we decided to domesticate dogs
instead of domesticating rats and ever
since then it has been dog is a man's
best friend as opposed to rats are a
man's best friend and we in turn
basically hate rats now the other part
of this is that rats are responsible for
things like the black plague right you
know the black death i mean rats have
have like crossed humanity a lot over
the years
but nonetheless right dogs have killed
people as well so it's just one of those
things where it's like people just
arbitrarily do things and most people
just do things because it's what they're
supposed to do as opposed to giving it
any real thought right kind of
sleepwalking through their life based on
a preview i guess a set of previously
established ideologies and so he's like
i just don't see it right he's like i
just don't understand it i don't get why
people are that way now the reality in
terms of why people are that way because
dogs are awesome man so once of course
he gets back to his van of course then
he's held up by some kind of a gang
banger right you know and then so at
that point he was like god he
he you know over the course of his life
has really just encountered nothing but
problems from humanity and in turn is
like humanity sucks now apparently this
guy had at one point right otis had
actually left gotham city at one point
and went to keystone city now there's no
indication made here about like jay
garrick or anything like that so we
don't know if the flash exists all he
really says is they've got cleaner
streets they've got faster internet and
then somebody beat him and stole his
shoes and he's like i don't understand
why everything is so horrible why it
seems like everybody is so mean and they
hate it he's like the only person that's
never hated me the only person that's
ever expressed any kind of of kindness
to him is actually batman and it was
only because of the fact that this guy
otis had been sent into a building in
order to basically clear out pests and
different things like that he was told
not to go to the 13th floor but he did
he ended up seeing what was going on on
the 13th floor and then ultimately they
were gonna throw him off a roof and then
batman ultimately saved him right so
batman literally saved his life the
other thing about this is that otis is
one of these guys right the thing about
people that nobody ever pays attention
to people that everybody always ignores
is they see things they see a lot of
things they're not supposed to see and
that's exactly what otis says it's like
i know exactly how you operate man i
know about your motorcycles right that
you keep in the sewers i know you use
the sewers to move around the city of
gotham so basically it looks like you
disappear and reappear right so it's one
of those things where like you just you
know you vanish and you're like on the
other side of town and nobody knows how
you got there because nobody saw you
moving above them but they never thought
to think that you were moving
underground he's like i know all that
kind of stuff he's like but here's the
thing though i can help you you know
they're they're you know the sewer
systems in the city of gotham i can show
you the secret ones i can show you the
ones that nobody knows about now the
funny thing about this is that if we're
talking about a main dc universe batman
comic batman would already know all that
and that's what makes this imposter so
cool and that's what really seems to
indicate this impostor story arc takes
place you know in the same universe as
robert pattinson's batman because it's
one of these things where we're
ultimately at least if you know from
what i glean from the trailers anyway
that basically robert pattins's batman
is seemingly relatively new that this
guy you know this this version of batman
has only been around for three years he
doesn't know the ins and outs of gotham
as well as a more seasoned batman would
but the thing about this is just one of
those scenarios where like he's
basically got somebody to help him now
and that's the thing that really makes
the difference so what you do is you
basically switch over to this kind of uh
this sort of juxtaposition regarding how
detective wong is looking over this
entire situation regarding the batman
and how batman himself is looking over
the deaths of these three individuals
they're basically both investigating the
exact same crime scene but coming to it
from two different directions that wong
is looking at it and saying okay right
the murder development is just
escalation right there's nothing special
or unique about this that is basically
just the next logical step in a guy that
is essentially a vigilante the guy that
takes the law into his own hands and
beats people up it was only a matter of
time before he killed someone and then
the question she asked is like is it
just is this some kind of hidden motive
or just an inevitable byproduct she's
like we found records of like 20
motorcycles that have been impounded and
nobody came asking for them which
basically meant that those things were
bought legally and whoever it is that
owns them will just replace them with
new ones right because it's easier to do
that and stay under the radar than it is
to show up and say i need my motorcycles
back because then people are gonna start
asking questions you know in turn you
have batman looking over all this and
it's like the victims are all convicted
criminals right all of them know how to
handle themselves the impostor managed
to get them onto the roof unnoticed he
was also clever enough to stay out of
sight until he wanted to be seen combine
those two facts and that tells me he's
tactical possibly military he's like
personal vendetta against these these
individual criminals i don't know right
just kind of going through i mean even
ask the question is this someone who is
finishing something or are they simply
just getting started right now at that
point that's when detective wong is like
i'm gonna have to find my you know find
some kind of information on or at least
get some information that wouldn't be
readily available to me that means going
to the criminal underworld and they all
shoot her down right oswald cobblepot
the black mask uh you know wesker they
all basically shoot her down they're
like we're not giving you anything right
even the people who are asking her and
the reason why is because the kind of
information she's asking for is the kind
of information that could be used to
incriminate all of these guys and no one
is going to offer any kind of
information that could be used in an
investigation where this information
leads to more information that leads to
more information that gets them busted
as you guys know when it comes to
ultra wealthy people who are criminals
in the batman universe they keep it very
hush-hush right they very much keep
things to themselves and so switching
back over to batman when he's
investigating this he says the first
step is to see what connects the victims
right they weren't cellmates they didn't
travel in the same circles they never
knew each other they didn't live even
remotely close to each other in the city
of gotham and he says this feels like a
vice grip right if he kills again i'll
have more data if he kills again the
cops will come harder turn the lever and
squeeze and he says but he's feeling
that vice too if he has a longer hit
list he's got until they capture or kill
me to keep himself hidden and there's
always the chance that the gotham city
police department catches him first and
so ultimately while all this is going on
and while he's musing on this there's a
knock at his door and that's when he
realizes that detective wong is
basically coming and asking him
questions about the nature of the batman
with that being said guys we're going to
bring this video to an end god i love
this imposter story arc it is just so
good it's just it's just ridiculously
phenomenal but thank you all for
watching and i will catch you all later
peace